con lágrimas en los ojos y rifles en las
manos cientos de palestinos organizaron
un funeral masivo en honor a ocho de los
fallecidos durante la redada israelí en
el campo de refugiados de la ciudad de
yenín entre los fallecidos está el
vecino de samaha que menciona murió en
sus brazos porque las fuerzas israelíes
bloquearon el acceso a las ambulancias
su herida estaba en el cuello era como
si le hubieran partido la cabeza no
pudimos tratarlos
estaba sangrando y no dejaban que
viniera la ambulancia no dejaron que
nadie llegara hasta aquí
la mayor operación militar del ejército
de Israel desde la segunda intifada tuvo
lugar aquí en el campo de refugiados de
llenín hogar de unas 14.000 personas que
recuerdan los horrores experimentados en
los dos días de intensos asaltos
israelíes
nos sorprendió un gran número de
militares del ejército entraron en la
zona en las casas de nuestros vecinos y
en la nuestra desalojaron a la gente de
sus casas y colocaron a sus
francotiradores detuvieron a muchos
jóvenes y nos utilizaron como escudos
humanos delante de ellos dispararon con
fuerza sobre nuestras cabezas mientras
caminábamos con ellos fue intenso
en medio de las preocupaciones
internacionales por las acciones de tel
aviv el Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu declaró que acciones similares
van a continuar